bonjour à tous soyez les bienvenus à
sens dans l'yonne france 3 bourgogne
vous fait vivre les festivités des huit
cent cinquante ans de la première
cathédrale gothique de france nous
sommes au balcon avec vue imprenable
mais tout à l'heure vous découvrez un
spectacle est étonnant une mise en
lumière de la façade des rosaces ce sera
magnifique et nous vous donnerons
j'espère envie de revenir dans le
courant de l'été voir ce spectacle sera
proposé tout au long de la saison
estivale donc dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission un document vous révélera
tous les secrets ou presque du monument
du parvis jusqu'au palais synodal juste
à côté récemment rénové nous
découvriront les trésors de la
cathédrale est également nous
reviendrons sur les traditionnelles
fêtes de lanne organisé chaque année
mais pour commencer par ton 138 marche
plus bas au comme vous êtes petit liseré
g sur l'esplanade de cette cathédrale
bonjour vous êtes auprès des sénonais
oui bonjour à nos effectivement je me
sens un peu petit ici un petit peu seul
aussi sur cette première partie de
parvis et de la cathédrale saint-etienne
de sens n'ont pas rassuré vous quand
même
les sénonais commencent à arriver ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux on va les
découvrir
juste derrière nous ils ont rangé les
parapluies pour l'instant parce qu'il ne
peut que pleut quasiment plus il ya
quand même des familles
il ya du mans il ya des petits curieux
et puis il tient une famille de deux
sénonais que j'ai rencontré tout à
l'heure qui va nous dire un petit mot
bas il entraîne trop de la cathédrale en
photo alors quand même on essaie de
néo-pros sa cathédrale en voilà pourquoi
vous êtes venus ce soir va pourvoir les
huit cent cinquante ans de la cathédrale
de sens à quoi vous vous attendez un
beau spectacle
merci beaucoup alors vous ne voyez ça
c'est une famille il ya des gens qui
sont venus entre amis il ya des jeunes
et tous les âges ici et puis vernon on a
encore beaucoup de choses à dire ce soir
sur cette cathédrale de sens et sur ce
spectacle qui nous attend très bientôt
frustre beaucoup n'ont qu'un sens et ça
se précise vous allez découvrir cette
mise en lumière restait bien avec nous
et parmi les artisans de cette
projection un allumeur d'image c'est un
peu comme ça que vous vous définissez
oui franck marty bonne chose bon
vous êtes l'auteur d'autres mise en
lumière de beaucoup de bâtiments si on
parle de la place stanislas de nancy de
chartres du parlement de bretagne à
rennes tout ça c'est vous donc une
certaine expérience
mais chaque bâtiment différentes voilà
la spécificité de notre travail et qu'on
travaille sur des des édifices qui ont
une histoire donc chez nous aucun
copier-coller possible parce que
vraiment vous adapter à la forme des
tours des rosaces de la moindre
sculptures de vous sert de base de
travail de palettes totalement le
bâtiment représente est essentielle dans
notre travail dans sa charge d'émotion
dans son histoire
et donc on ne peut pas l'oublier à aucun
moment c'est très poétique
on ne fait pas l'histoire c'est pas eu
150 ans d'histoire racontée année par
année non du tout évidemment on s'appuie
sur les faits de l'histoire mais c'est
un voyage impressionniste politique une
grande place à l'imagination en fait des
spectateurs les spectateurs vont le
découvrir dans les prochaines minutes ça
fait quoi
vous avez déjà vu des répétitions vous
savez que ça fonctionne bien mais de
voir une première comme ça on ressent
quelque chose en tant que directeur
artistique qui connaît un petit
pincement une première est toujours un
moment très particulier de voir tous ces
gens sur la place fallu évidemment un
moment d'émotion donc voilà la pluie
s'est arrêtée détracteurs maintenant
place au spectacle ont enfin vous très
bien
le maître d'oeuvre 10 afin que mes
frères s'élève vers la lumière de notre
seigneur qu'on suive précisément les
traits de marais
oh
nous
11 164 le pape alexandre iii
consacre la cathédrale saint-etienne de
sens
il y a huit cent cinquante ans
non
le
et
mr
ou grand le cerf
dans ce nouvel art né à sens
d'autres cathédrales du pays de france
puiseront le secret de leurs lumières
saint cyr et sainte julitte à nevers
notre dame de paris
la cathédrale saint-etienne de l'eau
saint pierre et saint paul à 3
la cathédrale saint-etienne de serre
c'est un te crois
orléans
le maître d'oeuvre a dit
les traits de ma règle
et qu'on ouvre alors
de larges fenêtres
afin
ses lèvres
à
m
l'an-12 155 et 12 latour cas mettant les
sénonais commença à tourner
plusieurs personnes ont péri
et le troisième jour
la ruine fut complète
comme le soleil se lève chaque jour la
cathédrale sortira des ténèbres de sa
ruine
et la lumière
jouera de nouveau
avec les hanches
oh
à
et
s
la fin
à
e
vous
à
non
mon
applaudissements nourris
pour cette mise en lumière de la
cathédrale de sens
la première à vivre donc ce week-end sur
france 3 bourgogne dindar brousse on
vous retrouve historiens vous êtes
toujours sous le charme là vous l'avez
déjà vu plusieurs fois cette mise en
lumière les répétitions là un show
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
on ne s'en lasse pas c'est merveilleux
je crois que c'est le livre des
merveilles en quelque sorte la
l'enluminure vivante et de la cathédrale
de sens là qui la met en valeur
regardera les splendides et là nous
sommes dans de merveilleux
on est dans le web le merveilleux c'est
le seul mot on se dit des fois
comment comment font-ils exactement la
technique moderne vient au secours d'un
art millénaire c'est parfait nous avons
une bonne étoile
elle est levée sur vous et sur sens ce
soit surtout les spectateurs très
nombreux liste vous êtes parmi eux ou
êtes-vous je ne vous vois pas oui super
bon moment c'est vraiment comment on
apprécie beaucoup et puis ça fait vivre
un petit peu la ville de sens et notre
place qui est magnifique
bien sûr vous en être fiers de vous
trouver ici vraiment sur cette place
ah ben oui c'est clair a travaillé sur
la place de la cathédrale et où sierre
et vos clients alors est ce qu'ils vont
devenir plus nombreux avec cet événement
qui va continuer d'ailleurs
oui déjà depuis
les essais qui a eu de la cathédrale par
les éliminations c'est vrai que ça a
attiré beaucoup de monde et les gens
nous demandent à chaque fois les dates
du week-end donc c'est vrai que ça va
nous attirer du monde
on vient vers vous dès que vous le
souhaitez le père françois campagnac et
avec moi bonjour
enfin vous êtes le curé de la cathédrale
de sens oui alors voir transformer c'est
un peu chez vous comme cette cathédrale
voir se transformer en écran géant ça
vous donne quels sentiments quelle
impression
ah ben je trouve que c'est vraiment une
belle occasion de fêter cette cathédrale
quand même c'est vrai de voir cette
cathédrale illuminée plein de lumière
pour j'avais dit revivre la même
intuition que les bâtisseurs au xiiie
siècle celle de faire entrer la lumière
dans la cathédrale mais aussi la lumière
dans nos coeurs les lignes de l'art
gothique c'était de nous élever vers le
ciel d'élever notre regard d'élever
notre coeur et je crois que le spectacle
on va voir ce soir nous aide aussi à
regarder vers le ciel est aussi élevé
nos vies vers le ciel alors le côté
religieux était marqué tout à l'heure
par cette procession procession est
également des confirmations un sacrement
important pour les catholiques confort
général après la communion dans sa
jeunesse là c'était 17 du ltte qui ont
effectué ce week-end leur confirmation
oui donc c'était aussi un grand
événement pour notre diocèse parce que
c'est vrai que 150 personnes adultes à
recevoir ce sacrement un sacrement
peut-être un peu moins connus
aujourd'hui que celui du baptême ou de
la première communion par exemple ou
celui du mariage aussi alors je crois
que c'est un bon signe pour notre église
aussi de voir que 150 adultes se sont
mis en chemin pour vivre
voilà sur les chemins de dieu pour
essayer de découvrir le souffle que dieu
pouvez le donner dans leur vie en
présence de personnalités des évêques
des américains et puis bien sûr le nonce
apostolique c'est-à-dire l'ambassadeur
du saint siège en france donc le
représentant du pape
ici chez nous est ce qu'on ressent le
poids de l'histoire quand on officie
chaque semaine dans une cathédrale comme
celle ci est ce corso ses huit cent
cinquante ans alors oui on les ressent
mais pas forcément comme un point on les
ressent j'allais dire au contraire comme
un comme un souffle comme un dynamisme
huit cent cinquante ans vous rendez
compte ça fait huit cent cinquante ans
que cette grande dame accompagne la vie
des sénonais elle est là dans leur ligne
de vue elle est là dans leur paysage au
quotidien elles marquent leur propre
identité et je crois que c'est bien la
communauté chrétienne elle continue
d'habiter ce lieu de vie des
rassemblements comme ce soir où
d'accueillir tous ceux qui veulent
rentrer dans cette cathédrale pour vivre
un moment de vraie spiritualité donc le
palais synodal on a en parallèle a
repris des couleurs l'an dernier la
couverture du toit a été entièrement
refaite des gargouilles ont été changés
également nous avons suivi ce chantier
avec des bâtisseurs des temps modernes
revoyons cela avec et béatrice comptoir
baasiste chaouti et christophe gaillard
une mosaïque de couleurs superbes digne
d'un tableau
voilà ce que composent ses couvreurs
charpentiers les échafaudages sont
impressionnants nous sommes sur le toit
du palais synodal de sens ils sont cinq
harnaché à plusieurs dizaines de mètres
du sol à poser cloud et des tuiles
vernissées
et peu à peu un puzzle multicolores ses
formes
ça c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut
refaire comme c'était avant
exactement pareil donc on a dû retracer
plus
pour tomber exactement pareil avec le
versant leur côté avec les couleurs
différentes
des tuiles rouge noire verte ou jaune
mais de différentes ont obligation de
suivre les plans et relever traces et au
préalable pour ne pas se tromper
un gros travail de préparation a été
fait en amont les tuiles en fait
étriller poser la fonction des couleurs
et de leur place on appelle ça le
brochage au sol un autre chantier
titanesque le chargement des gargouilles
celle ci pèse 350 kilos et il faut
quatre personnes pour la montée
verticalement à une quinzaine de mètres
la manoeuvre y physique stressante et
requiert d'infinies précautions
la moindre erreur
déjà ça décalerait le chantier ça serait
catastrophique et puis c'est quand même
des compagnons qui ont travaillé pour
sculpter cette gargouille on a en charge
de la poser est donc effectivement si on
si on commet une erreur ça c'est un
leurre matic il faudra ensuite mettre la
gargouille à l'horizontale pour
l'installer dans son logement
selon la méthode dite pour tiroirs des
tailleurs de pierre des sculpteurs
plusieurs corps de métiers cohabitent
sur ce chantier colossal est capital
pour l'état en respect pour nos anciens
nous ont transmis sur des bâtiments qui
ont traversé des siècles se doit au
moins dé conserver airs et pérenniser
pour les générations futures
et deuxièmement un attrait touristique
il faut savoir que la cathédrale amène
des gens du monde entier
en tout 62 mille pièces colorées auront
été posés pour restaurer entièrement le
toit la nouvelle tuile ont une durée de
vie d'un siècle
le chantier qui revient à 1 million
d'euros doit se terminer à la fin du
mois
on va partir sur le parvis de cette
cathédrale lise rige et vous êtes avec
quelqu'un qui a admiré avec un oeil
particulier ce spectacle hé bé oui
forcément il y ait dû avoir une sauce
sensibilité particulière père campagne
avec l'art on est devant votre
cathédrale magnifique une émotion
intense
bah oui une émotion intense d'émotion
intense pour bat pour tout le monde
une émotion intense pour tous ceux qui
étaient sur la place voilà ce que
c'était vraiment très beau c'est
vraiment éblouissant de voir cette
cathédrale reprendre des couleurs comme
au moyen-age les couleurs qu'elle avait
voilà se remplir de lumière voilà et
j'étais moi très sensible de voir tous
les yeux vraiment émerveillé les petits
comme les grands émotion que ça montre
bien qu'une cathédrale quand même ça
rassemble tous ça rassemble tout le
monde fait en toutes les générations
même que l'on soit croyant ou pas la
cathédrale c'est vraiment un vecteur
pour vivre ensemble il se trouve que ici
ce soir à 100 sur la bien montré je vais
me rapprocher de gilles pierre mans vous
aussi on peut dire que c'est une
réussite finalement ce spectacle la
réponse à cette question elle est devant
nous c'est à dire la foule qui s'est
rassemblé malgré la pluie
chose très rare à sens la pluie
pour profiter de cette grande première
qui vient mettre en lumière au sens
propre comme au sens figuré la
cathédrale qui la met en lumière notre
ville notre bassin de vie aussi puisque
tout cela permet de marquer un grand
anniversaire mais un anniversaire c'est
pas nécessairement une fin ça peut être
un démarrage et on compte beaucoup ici
s'agisse de l'archevêché mais aussi des
élus sur un démarrage particulier en
cette année 2014 sens qu'ils avaient
besoin d'un coup de projecteur
véritablement ça a commencé aussi avec
avec la cathédrale oui la cathédrale et
est le lieu central c'est le coeur de la
ville c'est c'est son âme aussi d'une
certaine façon et puisse est un élément
phare pour faire parler de sens aix ans
qui est enchâssé entre paris orléans et
3 et qui a besoin aujourd'hui de se
faire connaître
il faut qu'on dise ah oui sens je sais
où c'est est pas ça commence c ou sens
voilà ces phrases à doit être banni du
vocabulaire et planifie a beaucoup de
choses à découvrir à censier pas que la
cathédrale parlez nous un petit peu des
expositions qui vont être à découvrir
notamment tout cet été vous l'avais dit
à la cathédrale il y a trente trois
monuments classés public ou privé pour
une ville de 30 mille habitants c'est
énorme
il y avait évidemment tout ce qui a été
fait autour de cet anniversaire des
expositions de photographie amateur de
peintures de sculptures autour de la
cathédrale
une exposition à la façon des jardins du
luxembourg autour des halles baltard
face à la cathédrale avec des images
inédites des coraux des bals du sud et
le sec
j'en oublie probablement des rodin et
puis des photographies contemporaines
et puis des conférences qui ont eu lieu
des concerts la garde républicaine le
l'ensemble marc antoine charpentier et
j'oublie pour septembre puisque c'est un
rendez vous à venir
le 20 septembre ici même sur le parvis
un concert particulier nous donneront
les orgues de la cathédrale de
retransmise en son et lumière et puis
des orgues de feu du ciel at appris
beaucoup de choses jean pierre mans il
s'en passe des choses à changer
énormément on va vous retrouver arnaud
puisque ça s'achève bientôt c'est à vous
merci lisez oui il est temps de
remercier toutes les équipes de france 3
qui ont permis la réalisation de cette
édition spéciale de puissance et
j'espère qu'on vous a donné envie de
venir
durant cet été donc le vendredi et le
samedi à la tombée de la nuit
vous verrez cette mise en lumière tout
au long de l'été jusqu'au 13 septembre
vous restez avec nous tout de suite un
autre rendez vous avec l histoire votre
magazine pourquoi chercher plus loin de
revient sur la glorieuse histoire de
sens et de sa cathédrale très bonne fin
de week end sur france 3
et